staying on roe v wade for a second here
i just saw this right before showtime i
want to read through it a little bit
it's a horrifying editorial in the new
york times arguing
that it's better to kill babies than
adopt them
adoption is bad is the pitch
right so here is this is from um
elizabeth spyers who's a
democratic digital strategist
and she was adopted as an infant and her
point what's the headline
i was adopted i know the trauma it can
inflict
so it's a long we can't read the whole
thing but let's go through a little bit
of this on wednesday as the supreme
court heard oral arguments from state
attorneys seeking to uphold
mississippi's 15-week abortion ban
justice amy coney barrett kept getting
at one question
why was abortion necessary when women
who do not want to be mothers can simply
give their babies up for adoption
as an adoptee myself i was floored by
justice barrett's assumption that
adoptionism is an accessible and
desirable alternative for women who find
themselves unexpectedly pregnant
she may not realize it but what she's
suggesting is that women
don't need access to abortion because
they simply they can simply go do a
thing that is infinitely more difficult
expensive dangerous
and potentially traumatic than
terminating a pregnancy during its early
stages
as an adoptive mother herself
justice barrett should have some inkling
of the complexities of adoption and the
toll it can inflict on children as well
as birth mothers
okay i don't where do you even begin
with something like this
adoption is more dangerous
than abortion
now clearly we're only we're only
talking we're not taking the child into
account at all here yet
i don't know if we're going to get to
the point where she argues that it's um
better for the child also to be
dismembered and have his skull crushed
than to be put up for adoption maybe
she'll argue that later but right now
she's talking about the woman presumably
and so she says it's it's more dangerous
for the woman to put their child up for
adoption than to get an abortion
how so there's there's no physical
danger involved whatsoever and putting
your child up for adoption
um
and and most states say this is
something that amy coney barrett talked
about
that most states or maybe every state
now have laws on the books that
make it intentionally very very easy
for a child from for a parent to give
their child up
for adoption
so certainly not dangerous now we
compare that to abortion
even according to the the leftist
euphemistic way of talking about it it's
a it's a it's a quote-unquote medical
procedure it's a quote-unquote surgery
and there are always dangers in any
surgery
and those dangers are going to outweigh
you know bringing your child somewhere
to uh to give them up for adoption
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady and
gain the respect you deserve you know
we've been telling you about this i have
gone through this process myself i lost
my frame somehow because we only have
one
you know michael also is a lord now we
only have one frame between us so we
keep switching off the frames i mean we
are lords we are lords of our own
estates in scotland and we can only get
one frame but anyway um this is the uh
the certificate that you get and this
proves that i am lord matt walsh that is
my official name that is my preferred
pronoun established titles is a project
based on historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you'll receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land in a
private state and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number which you can see the exact
location of your land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady get get it on
your credit card your plane tickets et
cetera established titles is having a
great limited time sale so go to
establishtitles.com slash matt walsh to
save 10 off today remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's
establishedtitles.commattmulch
or just click the link below this
particular surgery is surgery quote
unquote is far more dangerous than most
we don't we don't talk about that i mean
these are women who are erased from the
public consciousness and conversation
but there are many many women out there
thousands and thousands of women out
there if not more who have suffered
long lasting phys these long-lasting
physical effects of abortion
including sometimes permanent
infertility and uh and other things as
well i mean if you want to know about
the the dangers of abortion go go check
in with
gosnell the serial killer up in
philadelphia who's in prison
now you know multiple women were killed
by gosnell
and he's not the only one that's done
that
and then potentially traumatic
okay so
giving your child up for adoption
is that a traumatic event
well i can certainly see that that it
would be
you know that's a i could see the the
emotional trauma that would be involved
in making that decision
but let's compare that to killing your
child
okay because with
the regret that comes later you've made
a decision that cannot be reversed
so on one hand
you've given your child to another
family that can care for them
and wants to care for your child
and even in spite of all of the
emotional trauma which i'm sure
is uh is
pronounced you know that your child is
out in the world
living
and there's a chance that they could a
very good chance
just like anybody else that they could
go on to live a very happy and fulfilled
and joyful life
so there's that
and then there is removing your child
from the world permanently
and then you you you move on from that
knowing that your child your child is
nowhere and you can't go back
there is a void now where your child
once was that will never be filled
what's more traumatic we wonder um she
continues
let's see
skipping ahead a little bit
the wright likes to suggest that
abortion is a traumatic experience for
women a last resort a painful memory but
adoption is often just as traumatic as
the right thinks abortion is if not more
so as a woman has to relinquish not a
lump of cells but a fully formed baby
she has lived with for nine months
i may mother myself to an adorable
six-year-old self-proclaimed
fortnite expert and as is a of course
her six-year-old plays fortnite
obviously
no big surprise there
um and as is often the case i did not
know why would you
you're this is not the point at all i
realize but you're six year old
you have your six-year-old playing
fortnite
my kids barely know what a video game is
okay let's not focus on that and as is
often the case i did not know i was
pregnant with him until the usual
symptoms appeared a few weeks into
pregnancy as anyone who has just stated
a human will tell you there's a vast
difference between the fourth week of
pregnancy and the 40th by the 40th
you're familiar with your baby's regular
rhythms of kicking and moving when i
awoke my son would wake up shortly after
and i'd feel him turning and stretching
or less pleasantly jamming his precious
little foot into what felt like my
cervix this is one of the paradoxes of
pregnancy something alien is usurping
your body and sapping you of nutrition
and energy but you're programmed to
gleefully enable it and you become
desperately uh protective of it
it's she's talking about talking about
her own child now and using the word
it's
it's a kind of biological brainwashing
and this often often happens whether you
want to be a parent or not
my god
i feel so bad for this child
your own mother referring to you as as
it and saying that her love for her
child is uh is by is the product of
biological brainwashing
yeah this is how these people see
children i said yesterday they really
they hate children they hate babies
they hate their own kids
whatever kids they've allowed to live
they hate them and resent them
because they see this as a zero-sum game
it's a it's an us or them kind of thing
and children are usurping they're taking
away my freedom my liberty
they're taking away my autonomy they're
a burden
that's the way they see it
and so as i skim ahead in this in this
article i was waiting for her to make
the case i mean she's talking about how
adoption is better for women which is
insane
but what about the baby issues is she
gonna try to make the case that it's
better for the baby and the answer
appears to be no because the baby
doesn't factor in at all who cares about
the baby
his his needs
what's best for him is not does not
factor in we're not talking about it who
cares
because he's a non-entity
[Music]
a clump of cells
as elizabeth spire puts it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content